God knew they couldn't be on this earth
without each other
he had to bring them home to heaven
together Vanessa Bryant delivered a
heartbreaking speech honoring her
husband Kobe and their 13 year old
daughter Gianna at their celebration of
life on Monday Kobe and Gianna naturally
gravitated towards each other she was
very much like her daddy
and that they both liked helping people
learn new things and master them they
were great teachers a source tells DT
that Vanessa knows the grieving process
will be long and hard they added that
she found the memorial to be healing
vanessa is overwhelmed with the
outpouring of love her and her family
received it was the perfect tribute to
Kobe and Gigi among those tributes a
powerful piano performance by Alicia
Keys she honored the Laker legend by
playing Beethoven's moonlight sonata
the classic Sonata holds a lot of
meaning for the couple
Kobe learned to play it by ear so we
could serenade Vanessa he starts playing
this familiar tune unlike the WHO that I
know this to who is it and a security is
like it's Beethoven I'm like what I'm
like he's like yeah he taught us out
Beethoven in like two weeks
like what the hell are you kidding me
and he was playing the piano like it was
nothing and it was just incredible to me
that when he locked in on something
nothing with there was no berries he'd
he tapped into that other side of the
brain that people don't get a chance to
use like he knew how to get to that
other side NBA legend Michael Jordan
also spoke at Kobe's celebration of life
he broke down in tears as he remembered
his little brother I might him because
his passion you rarely see someone who's
looking and trying to improve each and
every day not just in sports but as a
parent as a husband I am inspired about
what he's done and what he shared with
Vanessa and what he's shared with his
kids but the most emotional speech of
all was Vanessa's sharing touching
stories about her baby girl Gigi she
loved family traditions family movie
night and game night on vacations were
important to her did you always looked
out for everyone she was very much in
tune with our feelings and wanted the
best for us and the mother of four
called Kobe the MVP of girl dads and
praised him for being a doting father he
always told the girls how beautiful and
smart they are he taught them how to be
brave and how to keep pushing forward
when things get tough you take care of
our chichi
and I got Nani Bibi and Coco we're still
the best team
[Music]
you